encore quatre questions c'est ça
non non non
ok pourquoi tu as dit ok à la fin de ta
phrase j'ai pas dit OK
magnifique où elle appelle
durant la bataille est-ce que tu as vu
le Home de Dijon
bien excellent et tu sais ce que
grimoulf on a fait
quand les cultes ont atteint la crête on
était plus nombreux que mais notre
avantage ne pesait pas lourd face à
raccord le dragon
prends ça et puis il ne doit pas tomber
entre les griffes de raccords
merci pour ton aide faut trouver la
tombe de stanard
grimouldes pas les trois dernières
questions à quoi bon tout ce qui savait
il nous l'a dit tu peux pas le laisser
comme ça regarde le pauvre vieux
ah c'est vrai
ta nourriture préférée
tu aimes les chats
de plus de égal je suis nul en match
tu te sens pas mieux là non
souvent la décision la plus lourde à
prendre pour le chef et de battre en
retraite
j'ai donné cet ordre
j'ai chargé mon seigneur de bataille de
donner le home à notre cavalier le plus
rapide une seule affine si
on a réussi reparti
c'était le matin de la bataille
alors que je sortais de mon bain j'ai
glissé sur une pierre
et après ça tu as les battre non je suis
mort à cause de ma chute les grimoulf a
dit qu'il avait confié le home à Vence à
la fin c'est bien toi
je suis svens à la fine c'est mon petit
frère
ben va bien
j'ai été blessé et j'ai perdu mon cheval
en quittant le champ de bataille ma vie
m'importait peu il fallait que je
protège le home
c'était un teint qui portait la marque
de zazam
j'ai attendu le coup de grâce
qui n'est jamais venu
il s'est montré gentil il m'a dit qu'il
s'appelait zincenda il avait rejeté
instame et vivait désormais en exil
alors que je mourrai il m'a promis de
veiller sur le home
ce qui est zinc c'est un paladin il a
aidé l'enclave contre l'éclair de Talos
j'en ai entendu parler mon oncle dit
qu'il a fait fuir un petit rail avec
juste une courge bien aiguisée une
courge bien aiguisée enfin un truc
aiguisé les TVA sont des meurtriers et
ça s'arrête là
quoi je connais aussi le bonhomme mon
cousin et lui son battus dans la Nora
qui dit que c'est un type bien bon vous
n'avez qu'à retrouver cette incroyable
Xen qui prend le thé avec lui je
trouverai un autre moyen
il a eu une embrouille avec les théiens
je sais ce que tu peux ressentir mais on
a plus de temps à perdre
ça reviendrait à trahirt au contraire
ton but se régler sauvé et qui ira
écoute si zen s'avère être un con je le
couperai moi-même en morceaux
c'est tellement adorable on peut tenter
le coup
quelqu'un sait où se planque ce crétin
génial des ménestres
avec allez on y va
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
je suis toujours vivant ouais
le livre que tu aimes le plus
c'est difficile de choisir
c'était la cinquième ça oui
que je dirais le grimoire des crocs
je n'étais que la quatrième question
vous êtes là
oh merde
pas la fin de la bataille on devient
amoureux les filles se prennent leur
père et frère dans leurs bras ce qui
crois
èrent le son comme deux vieux frère
oh que les trous Badour chantent l'amour
ce qui croisèrent le frère sont comme de
vieux frères que les trous bas nous
changent trop ballon chante troubadours
chante trop badourchante
j'ai le pied coincé
[Musique]
la chambre de Kira doit être là-haut
trouver la sale forte et on vous rejoint
trouve la salle je devrais t'aider
peut-être pas ça fait toujours plaisir
[Musique]
ils viennent de monter